ja und im phoenix tagesgespräch ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet nils schmid der
außenpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion es mit das offizielle
amtsenthebungsverfahren hat ja nun
begonnen wird das was aus ihrer sicht
es kommt jetzt erscheint auf das
verhalten der republikaner an aber es
ist ein gutes und überfälliges signal
dass ein erneutes im richmond verfahren
jetzt angestrengt worden ist denn donald
trump hat die amerikanische verfassung
and er der hat die amerikanische
demokratie besucht seine ganze amtszeit
ist geprägt durch rassismus und andy
demokratisches verhalten und dem muss
ein riegel vorgeschoben werden
deshalb ist es gut dass jetzt dieses
zweite verfahren läuft aber die frage
war ja was glauben sie wie es ausgeht
wie sie sind ja experte auf dem gebiet
was sie ihre einschätzung
es ist zu befürchten dass die
republikaner im senat erneut nicht
diesem impeachment zustimmen
aber es ist auch zugleich eine
bewährungsprobe für die republikanische
partei insgesamt ob sie weiterhin trumps
partei sein will oder ob sie als
demokratische kraft jenseits der
verehrung für trump bestehen will
ich habe die hoffnung dass der
mehrheitsführer mcconnell ein klares
signal gibt aber meine einschätzung ist
dass es wieder nicht reichen wird für
eine amtsenthebung und dass die
republikaner sich damit einmal mehr mit
traums verhalten gemein machen was für
die amerikanische demokratie kein gutes
zeichen wäre jetzt gibt es ja stimmen
die sagen diese amtseinführung würde
vielleicht zu sehr ablenken von dem was
was kommt von joe biden präsidentschaft
was denken sie darüber
ich finde das verhalten von donald trump
so schwerwiegend und so einmalig in der
jüngeren geschichte der amerika der
amerikanischen demokratie dass eine
bestrafung durch eine amtsenthebung
unbedingt erforderlich ist
einerseits um deutlich zu machen dass
trump nicht wieder für das
präsidentenamt
die tieren kann in vier jahren durch ein
erfolgreiches impeachment verfahren
würde das auch ermöglicht das verhindert
und es muss auch deutlich gemacht werden
dass radikale kräfte in der
amerikanischen politik keine zukunft
haben dass ein solches verhalten in
zukunft sich nicht wiederholen darf
deshalb ist eine verfolgung durch ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren oder später auch
vor gericht unbedingt erforderlich um
die amerikanische demokratie von diesem
dämonen trump zu befreien
diese sperrung des twitter-accounts
wurde ja auch heftig diskutiert was
sagen sie dazu
es ist richtig dass twitter versucht
regeln durchzusetzen ich würde es
vorziehen dass es der gesetzgeber selber
regelt nach welchen regeln nach welchem
verfahren twitter oder auch facebook
accounts gesperrt werden das ist keine
angelegenheit von privatunternehmen das
frei schnauze nach gusto zu regeln
sondern dafür braucht es
allgemeingültige regeln die dann nicht
nur für leute wie trump sondern für
autoritäre herrscher oder hitze in der
ganzen welt auch in anderen staaten
dieser erde gelten
jetzt haben wir ja die bilder eben
gesehen das bild das da 15 1000
nationalgardisten das kapital schützen
die da schon übernachten eindrucksvolle
bilder die zeigen in welchem
ausnahmezustand dieses land die stadt
washington dc eigentlich sind was
erwarten sie denn von diesem tag der
amtseinführung müssen wir uns da auf
weitere ich sag's mal gelinde gesagt
krawalle einstellen
also mir blutet das herz bei diesem bild
und wenn eigentlich ist die
amtseinführung ein hochamt der
demokratie ein großes fest der
demokratie in amerika aber gleichzeitig
bin ich auch zuversichtlich dass ein
erneuter sturm oder erneute
auseinandersetzung durch ausreichende
und vor allem auch rechtzeitige präsenz
von sicherheitskräften vermieden werden
kann und das ist noch mal das
entscheidende am tag der amtseinführung
dass das mit stil und ohne unruhen vor
sich gehen kann ich glaube das ist
diesmal gewährleistet blicken wir weg
von trump auf den neuen auftritt beiden
was erwarten sie von ihm jetzt sozusagen
aus der ausblick der deutschen aus der
deutschen sicht nun joe biden wird sich
erstmal ganz stark um die eigene
gesellschaft und das eigene land kümmern
müssen die korona pandemie schlägt
unvermittelt und unvermindert zu es gibt
wirtschaftliche und soziale spannungen
die angegangen werden müssen
ich bin aber überzeugt dass joe biden
sowie er das selbst sagt die wunden
heilen kann und dass er ein versöhnendes
präsident und auch einen versöhnen
regierungsstil an den tag legen wird und
entscheidend wird sein dass er trotz der
knapp mehrheit seiner partei in beiden
häusern des kongresses auf die
republikaner auf die opposition zugeht
und bei großen innen und
außenpolitischen vorhaben versucht eine
breite mehrheit zu schmieden ich bin
jedenfalls froh dass wir einen
vernunftgeleiteten überzeugten
demokraten jetzt wieder als
amerikanischen präsident und auch als
partner und freund deutschlands und
europas im amt sehen werden das heißt
trotzdem er sozusagen die republikaner
einbinden muss und wird erwarten sie
verbesserte deutsch-amerikanischen
beziehungen
auf alle fälle joe biden kennt europa
kennt deutschland er weiß um den wert
von bündnissen wie der nato er weiß um
den wert von internationaler
zusammenarbeit und internationalen
abkommen er wird wieder stärker mit
seinen freunden in der welt in erster
linie mit europa und deutschland
zusammenarbeiten
das wird für die außenpolitik ein großer
fortschritt sein denn endlich können wir
wieder gemeinsam mit unseren
amerikanischen freunden dinge besprechen
vielleicht auch mal streitig
ausdiskutieren aber gemeinsam sind wir
stärker und können auch auf der
weltbühne dann mehr erreichen
nils schmid war dass der außenpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion herzlichen
dank nach berlin
sehr gerne